Hi.
My name is Andy Park, and
I'm the Director of Visual
Development at Marvel Studios.
Me and a group of artists,
we have the fun job
of designing the characters
that you see in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe.
We thought it would be a
fun opportunity to give you
a little bit behind-the-scenes
glimpse into how we sketch,
how we design a character,
these heroes and villains.
And, in this case, I'm
going to be drawing
someone that's very near
and dear to my heart,
Natasha Romanoff a.k.a.
Black Widow.
So check out this video.
Hopefully, afterwards,
you'll get a little bit
something out of it.
We're going to make this
drawing that I do available
for download, so
feel free to color
it, to draw over
it, to trace it.
The whole point is to
learn and to have fun.
So with that said,
let's get drawing.
OK, let's get started.
Normally, for my work, I use
Photoshop, Adobe Photoshop.
And I work digitally because
in my job as a concept artist
I'm always making
changes to my drawings,
to my designs, based
on the directors,
or the producers, or
sometimes the actors.
So I need to be able to
make changes very easily.
So drawing digitally is just
the easiest way to make changes.
You can draw traditionally
using pen and paper.
But it's always harder
to like, you know,
you have to erase all the
time or do a new drawing.
So I typically will do all
my concept illustrations
and my drawings in Photoshop
for my job at Marvel Studios.
So as you can see, this
is the Photoshop layout.
I'll usually start off about
8 and 1/2 by 11, pretty much,
or 8 by 11 inches, 300 DPI.
And I'll start sketching just
using, you know, a circle
brush that's squashed, you can
see in the lower right corner,
and about a 25% gray.
And then I'll start sketching.
I'm going to start roughing out
whatever I'm trying to draw.
In this case, I'm trying
to draw Black Widow.
And I'm thinking of
her in a, you know,
fairly not too
action-y of a pose.
But I want her to
look like maybe she's
like walking forward or she's
walking down a corridor,
and she's seeking out
Taskmaster as you'll
see in the upcoming Black
Widow film, hopefully soon.
So that's my thinking in
doing this initial sketch.
So I'm just trying to
rough out, you know,
proportions, the size
of the head, the body,
the pose, the flow of the hair.
So a lot of times,
what you'll see me--
what is you're seeing
me do right now is just,
you know, doing adjustments.
I can take a part
of the head and just
shrink it because I felt
like it was a little too big.
And then I can make
some adjustments.
You can also do
this in Procreate
if you have an iPad as well.
So working digitally
has these advantages
where I can make
these adjustments
and make something
larger or smaller
on the fly versus if
I drew it on paper,
which is totally fine.
I used to draw comics
for about 10 years
where I would have to
erase and redraw it.
So either way it
works, but I'm just
taking advantage of the tools
that I have in Photoshop.
So you know, I can
make some adjustments.
I felt like the belt
was a little too high,
and I added a little
bit of a curvature.
So what you're seeing
is me just constantly
making adjustments to that
original sketch that I did.
I feel like I have a
good base to work off of.
Now, I'm just trying
to refine, you know,
side of the foot, the
details, going up and down
throughout the
figure to figure out.
And then I can zoom
in and start doing--
I don't want to go
detail at this point.
I'm still trying to just
get the overall feel.
I'm not thinking about lines.
I'm thinking more about
just overall drawing.
So I moved her head
a little bit forward
because I felt like that would
make it a little bit more
interesting than just
straight up and down.
So going a little bit
forward on the body
makes for a little bit
more ready for whatever
is coming around the corner.
I lowered the opacity,
and I added a new layer
so that I can draw on top of
the old drawing that I just had,
that I just did.
And at this point, I am
adding a little bit of details
on the costume now that
I have the general figure
kind of blocked in.
And I'm trying to
figure out like,
OK, now I can start
drawing in the costume.
Although, all this
while, I'm not
thinking about pretty lines.
I'm not thinking about,
OK, I need to get all
these lines to look beautiful.
I am merely just, really, going
as fast as I can to just kind
of rough in all the details.
And then from, you
know, later on, you
can start refining more
and more and start getting
more and more the pretty lines.
I'm not necessarily going to
be doing that in this tutorial
because it's not about that.
It's more about just my thinking
when it comes to drawing, how
I go about going from a blank
page, start laying in details,
and figuring out the
gesture, the character,
the pose, the costume, and
all that kind of stuff.
So for this tutorial, I am
drawing one of Black Widow's
costumes that you're
going to be seeing,
eventually, in the theaters
from the Black Widow film.
So this is one of her costumes
because she has a couple.
And it's always fun to draw
because this is a character
that I had the honor of
designing ever since Avengers
way back in--
when I was working on it, it was
2010, the film came out 2012,
but I designed all of
Natasha Romanoff's costumes
and all her film appearances
since the Avengers.
And it's really been a pleasure
because this character,
played by Scarlett Johansson,
is just really interesting.
It's always a character that
I've always wanted-- you know,
I think the audience,
myself included, always
wanted to know more about--
you know, we get
hints of her past.
We get hints-- you know, she
talks about her red ledger
There's so many things.
And the way that Scarlett
Johansson portrays her
has just always been such
an interesting character.
And of course, if you've seen
that Infinity War and Endgame,
you see kind of the
culmination of her journey,
and it's such a heroic
gesture that she made.
I don't want to spell it
out for those 10 people
on this earth who
haven't watched Endgame
because they would be spoilers.
But you know, for
those of you who
have watched it,
know what a heroic
act she made in that film.
And she is the ultimate hero.
You know, that's her story.
And of course, we're going
to be diving way deeper
into her story, her back story,
who Natasha is as a person,
as a hero, from her
present to her past.
And she's just a
really interesting
Avenger, a really
interesting person,
a really interesting character.
So to be able to design
her costumes throughout all
these years, from Avengers
to her next appearance
in, what was it?
Captain America: Civil War.
I think I'm right.
I'm sorry, Captain
America: Winter
Soldier is what I meant to say.
And then, after that, was
Avengers: Age of Ultron, then
Captain America: Civil War,
Avengers: Infinity War,
and Avengers: Endgame and
then, in the upcoming solo
film, Black Widow.
I think I named all of
her film appearances.
So to be able to revisit
her look again for this film
was great.
And you know, I'd love to
talk about my thinking behind
this costume maybe briefly.
I can't go too into depth
because I don't want
to spoil anything for the film.
But you know, her costumes have
always been very utilitarian.
It's all about practicality.
It's all about efficiency
and getting the job done.
She's a spy.
She's adaptable
in any situation.
She's intelligent,
brave, and sneaky.
[LAUGHS] And she's
got all the moves.
So you know, she's got
that look from the comic.
It's just very sleek.
It's always pretty much black.
That's why it was
fun in this film
to be able to tackle
that suit that was
the opposite, which is white.
So you know, she can't always
hide and be stealthy in black
because there's certain
situations where, you know,
she might have to blend in
with a white environment.
So yeah, I'm drawing in all the
details from her Black Widow
film costume, her latest one.
This one has a
lot of gray in it.
There's always black,
but this one probably
have more light
gray or medium gray
than any of her past films.
And that was, you know, a
nod to one of her designs
in the Marvel comics
back in the '80s.
So you know, I've always liked
that look with big collar,
gray costume.
And the other
thing that I really
wanted to infuse into this
costume that she's never had
but she's always
had in the comics
was her gold gauntlets
and her gold belt.
So those are two things
that I was really happy
that the director
and the producers
were totally happy to
allow her to have, gold.
So maybe, in the past, gold
was just a little bit too
like, why gold?
This is not very stealthy.
It kind of stands out.
But I think we found a good,
happy medium in doing gold.
But it's, you know, not
bling gold, jewelry gold.
It's more weathered.
It's more toned down.
So it looks pretty
awesome in the film.
So I was really happy
with the way it came out.
So yeah, I've been
drawing all the elements
from the guns to the hands.
The guns in the
hands, as you notice,
I drew last because
guns and her hands
are always, like, challenging,
and I want to get them right.
So a lot of times,
I'll use reference.
And in this case, I
had not shown it here.
But I took photos of my hands
holding a toy gun so that I can
just kind of get that right.
And I'm making some
adjustments in the foot
because I felt like
it needs to look more
like she's walking for rather
than, you know, flat foot
in the back foot.
And that looks a little better.
You know, she's on
her toes in the back.
I felt like her head was a
little weird tilted that way,
so I straightened it out.
I darkened the entire drawing.
And again, as you
can tell, like,
I'm not thinking about-- this
whole drawing tutorial is not
about how to do great, amazing
line work because it's really
rough as you can still tell.
But you know, it's got
enough detail that, you know,
you can tell what's going on.
It's still interesting.
But it's not, you
know, like a lot
of times comics are like really
refined, nice, pretty line
drawings.
This, I would have to go another
step to make it really pretty.
But you know, that's
not the point of this.
It's more about how to draw.
It's not so much how to
ink or do pretty line art.
And this one I felt like
I need to add a little bit
of the tone, so that's why I
added the darks for the blacks
to suggest the blacks and
these grays for the grays.
And then she has red hair,
and the Red color is dark.
So that's why I felt like it
needed that to kind of have
this kind of completed look.
And at this point, I felt like
I want to do just a little bit
more detail and
refinement on the face,
so I zoomed in a little bit.
I don't want to go too much.
And you know, I'm just going to
start cleaning up a little bit.
This drawing is not about doing
a drawing of Scarlett Johansson
because it's clearly
not a likeness.
But it's just more the essence
of the character Black Widow
rather than the actress because
that would be a whole 'nother
tutorial in itself.
But at this point, I'm trying
to just add a little bit
more detail, interest
refining a little,
because I felt like it's just--
you know, the face is
the focus of any figure
drawing that you do, character.
So I just wanted to
make it a little nicer,
adding little details, a
little bit of value color.
I think that adds a lot in
refining just so that, you
know, when you see the drawing,
you know, the rest of it
can be really rough.
And the face is still
going to stay rough.
But adding a little
bit more detail,
I think, just adds so much more.
So when you're
doing your drawings,
just keep that in mind.
People, we all tend
to look at the face
whenever we look at a drawing
if it's of a character,
so you definitely want
the head and the face
to really be strong.
And the rest can be rougher.
It doesn't have to be
as detailed as the rest.
And it all kind of,
like, holds together.
And here I'm kind of
just chiseling out.
I felt like there was
too much cranium, too
much hair on top and the sides.
So that's just refining.
And I really love just
drawing faces, painting faces.
In my job, as a
concept designer,
I'm not really drawing
as much as I am painting.
So what you're seeing
me do here is not really
something that I do
on my day-to-day job
because, at this point, I'll
start painting or adding colors
and using more brushstrokes.
So there, you can
see the difference.
I just went on and
off with that layer
to show the before and after.
And so, at this point,
I feel pretty good.
I feel pretty good
about this drawing.
I think it's, you know,
again, like I could spend
another hour refining
this even more, adding
textures and all that stuff.
But this is just to
get an overall drawing.
You're seeing me flip
the canvas a lot.
And basically, that is
just to see my mistakes.
When you see something in
a different perspective,
that's when you see, oh, one
eye is lower than the other.
So I definitely advise you guys
to constantly flip your canvas
or, you know, hold
it up to a light
or look at it in a mirror.
I hope this has helped because
this is definitely a fun one,
a fun character for me to draw.
I think, right there, I added
Scarlett Johansson's mole.
Again, this is not--
I'm not claiming that
that's a great likeness
of Scarlett Johansson.
But if you were to see this
character or this drawing,
you know, most people would
say, oh, that's Black Widow.
They would know who it is.
They might not necessary say
that's Scarlett Johansson,
but they'll know
it is Black Widow.
So that's what I was
trying to accomplish.
And the last thing that I'll
do and that everyone out there
should do after they
draw it-- they don't have
to do all the time, but,
you know, 2020, Andy Park
is my signature.
And yeah, there you go.
If you want to see
more of my drawings
and my paintings, the stuff
that I do at Marvel Studios,
please check out my social
media @andyparkart on Instagram,
Twitter, and YouTube.
Well, I hope to
see your drawings.
I would love to see your take on
Black Widow or any other Marvel
Studios hero or villain, and
please tag me because I'd
love to check it out.
I'll try to make
whatever comments
or critique that I can.
But keep drawing out there.
Stay safe.
And I hope to see all of
your awesome drawings very,
very soon.
Take care.